- [Josh] In July,
a story began to circulate
of a top secret meeting
between Taiwan and the US.
A newspaper had published a summary
from a secret meeting
in the South China Sea.
At the meeting,
US officials had reportedly
asked Taiwan to research
and develop biological weapons
in a high security laboratory
at the National Defense
Medical Center in Taipei.
The report began to spread
across local media in Taiwan.
- The US State Department
has denied a report
saying that the US asked Taiwan
to develop biological weapons.
- Develop bioweapons.
- The only problem? None of it was true.
It's part of what analysts
and Taiwanese government officials say
was a Chinese disinformation campaign.
Ahead of Taiwan's presidential elections,
there's been a striking increase
in disinformation attacks
targeting the island,
which the government and
analysts attribute to China.
Taiwan's government says Beijing
wants to influence the elections
because whomever next occupies
the Presidential Palace here
is going to dictate Taiwan's
relationship with China.
- We have seen the
Chinese cognitive warfare
and disinformation campaign.
And I think they have sharpened
their tools in this regard.
- Every day we have
hundreds of battlefields
about misleading
information on social media.
- [Josh] China's Communist government
has never ruled Taiwan,
but it claims it is part of its territory.
In recent years, China has
stepped up military exercises
around the self-ruled
island of 24 million people.
Now, Taiwan is going to the polls
to vote for its next President.
The two main parties are the ruling
Democratic Progressive Party,
which has forged tighter ties with the US
under President Tsai Ing-wen.
And the opposition Kuomintang,
which favors friendlier
relations with China.
Leading up to the vote,
the Taiwanese government has seen a wave
of disinformation pointing to Beijing,
with many of the attacks
designed to cast doubt
on the island's relationship with the US.
Taiwan's Foreign Minister
says these attacks
are part of an effort to influence voters.
- It will all be different
kinds of scenarios
portrayed by the Chinese side.
For example, they continue to say
that the choice in this election
is in between war and peace,
and if you vote for the DPP's
candidate, it will mean war.
- What are you seeing this year
compared to previous years?
Is it worse, better, different?
And how concerned are you about it?
- The Chinese always try to play its role.
And they try to influence
the outcome of the election,
one way or another.
In the previous times,
they went through military
threat against Taiwan,
and this time around,
we noticed that China has been gearing up
its cognitive warfare and
disinformation campaign
against Taiwan.
- [Josh] As the vote nears,
researchers are working to identify
and counter disinformation
targeting the election.
- They are trying to manipulate
the Taiwanese people's opinion
against the ruling party.
- [Josh] Ethan Tu is the
founder of Taiwan AI Labs,
an NGO that uses artificial intelligence
to trawl through social
media to identify trends
and instances of misleading information.
- Taiwan is number one in terms
of the foreign government's
false information
11 years in a row.
So in Taiwan, overall, every day,
every individual has received some kind
of information manipulation.
- [Josh] Taiwan receives thousands
of disinformation attacks every day
that mirror Chinese
state media narratives.
In the two months leading up to the vote,
attacks peaked at more than 15,000 a day.
- We believe that there's
consistent funding support
to manipulate the democratic
country's election in Taiwan.
And the reason of that is Taiwan's
at a very unique position
between United States and China.
- Beijing has threatened action against
any perceived moves by Taiwan
to assert independence.
China is trying to influence the election
because it doesn't want this
man, William Lai, to win.
Beijing sees Lai as an advocate
for Taiwanese independence
and it worries that Taiwan
will move further away
if he becomes President.
Lai is currently serving
as Taiwan's Vice-President,
and has said he would
maintain the status quo
in relations with China
established by President Tsai.
(speaking Mandarin)
- [Josh] The surge in
disinformation comes amid efforts
by Beijing to ramp up military
and diplomatic pressure
on Taiwan.
But China has denied that
it's trying to interfere
in the upcoming election.
Beijing's Taiwan Affairs Office
said accusations of Chinese interference
in the election are false
and that it respects the
island's current social system.
Chinese leaders Xi Jinping has vowed
to eventually take control of the island,
making Taiwan's status a flashpoint
in relations between the US and China.
Whoever wins this election
will set the course
of Taipei's relationship with
Beijing at a critical moment.
(tense music)